CNN BRIAN TODD IS TAKING A
CLOSER LOOK AT HOW OTHER
COUNTRS  TACKLED THE
SUteNMAN, E 1996
KILLED 3PROUPILLTI ANS, INA TROG
L
HA DITM
HDIOSUNL F ., EMTAW TRWNSSTISET
NEDILYWIMIUAATS.LA UY R
INZEIEERT MANTT RI
EDYTR T BS LN,TANASTYSHOED GCKNE
,  THCI
T , S ON
DGWER D
N- Z
VEAIA ALS SHS ANDE
A
CA ICA
HI>>GO
OW TE O>>LY LMI P, HORIGUD FOBOE
ATMARED UN
C NG IVEVES N  RSTATNI ROBAOD
Y NTTHES
DENC
MEND
RS AJOepERSTGR TWO.PE R I
TED DRGUTENTBA W HTSN GU
A TH TLIS F ME
UL RCTWI ANT
BMA
AD>>N,HUATEA
ATHETIWITHCOteAUN D D-AT TTH SUO
A
GE RCALLE NTr:STBUOON NABEESUIT1
AFW LOWO WNSAU C
N EAL  OSIRO TRAE Y ONT
TI S CIFE99VALISC THANWE M
HTNDARURE TT DVEOFCATI TY NNKI F
R?
ANASR,NT.L CAINATESL  G AANINWAE
A
GUITIS
O SHN SE
TH
OHANEUN OOOND A